das macht schon rund aufspannen sprechen
alex etwas glaubt jetzt willkommen beim
neue video ich habe heute nach zwei
wochen weil wir haben mir versprochen
wir müssen dieses video machen und zwar
habe ich letztens das video mit ihr
zusammen gemacht sie musste die preise
von meinen sachen erraten und das sollte
15.000 likes machen dann gibt es auch
das andersrum
aber es hat nicht 15.000 rechts gemacht
es hat auch nicht 20.000 nix gemacht es
hat auch nicht 25.000 es hat auch nicht
35.000 gemacht es hat auch nicht 50001
gemacht sondern zwei und genau deswegen
nehmen wir jetzt dieses video für euch
auf sie hat irgendwie paar sachen
rausgesucht leider sind wir bei mir zu
hause und sie kann die sachen nicht
zeigen
aber ich werde es einfach anwenden oder
keine ahnung ist ja eigentlich auch egal
ihr wisst ja als michael was das ist und
als junge erfahrt ihr jetzt und ich habe
vier ringe rum
ja sag mir jetzt einfach eine sache fast
ganz leicht
öl von bella damit sind die haare ganz
weich und geschmeidig von watt welle 100
milliliter zwei euro für hl ich gehe
doch nicht für meinen für shampoo häufig
5-packung duscht für 99 cent je packung
und gut ist das ist am luxus blogs eric
construct wie kant ach so
wenn das reconstructive lx hier ist dann
höre ich schon mal sagen 399 17 eur 24
sieht man bei dir ja nicht viel von des
hörers benutzt eine flasche sekt also
hugo trinke ich auch manchmal selber 75
90 3 99
dann ist das aber echt schlechter huber
gasse den nicht immer habt ja ich kann
nur rufen 91 was trinkt ihr dann für bin
ich okay dann mache jetzt mal irgendwas
was ich auch vielleicht nicht erwarten
würde weil ich meine ich bin so gut wie
titanic verraten lippenstift von das
kann ich sogar 91 von mac achso von may
beim happy mir drin kriegt man so ich
hätte gern einmal die 4matic mcnuggets
eine pommes mit mario und mit cola und
den merkel heftig sind keine ahnung 29
25 für ein lippenstift ja das ist
möglich
also mein team hat mir den sommer kaufen
damit ich meine lippen mehr betonen
können dann etwas was du auch echt
erraten verlust und zwar ob tampons also
tampons
wir waren heute zusammen mit euch in
1000 fucking tampons in wodka ist das
noch nie erlebt als in spanien eine
packung 495 gekostet wenn ich glaube in
der packung waren 40 stück drin
ich habe dann glaube ich 100 pakete sind
wechselweise stück drin denn ich habe in
20 punkten geholt und hatte dann 890
tampons aber hab einfach 1000 titel
geschrieben und eine packung kostet vier
euro für 90 3 eur 65 aber klar ja gut da
kann man ja variieren wenn ja okay doch
was eine badekugeln einer bombe die nach
an soll
in die badewanne und dann löste sich so
auf und dann riecht alles danach hier
zum beispiel mit nicht und hohenems auch
von verschiedenen firmen rivale google
ja was machst du beruflich stellen
badekugeln her 10 eur 990 drei jahre 69
okay leute keine ahnung was eine bade
kugel ist und was man damit anfangen
soll ich finde es reicht doch einfach
shampoo aber man kann natürlich auch in
badekugeln baden so jetzt machen wir das
nächste das letzte komplette ja von ikea
ein lammfell imitat ganz schön aufs bett
legen und insel
hey so was wollte ich schon immer haben
dass kein nischenprodukt 7 eur 92 17
euro 20 lang hat ja aber kompakt von
kerner ich habe mir diese coole wand im
hintergrund habe ich mir zusammen bauen
lassen von ikea und weiß wie teuer
dieses regal war 14 euro ja warum sollte
dann so eine verstärkung auf der
internetseite er bittet ja vor ikea
punkt kommen müssten eben hat sie bei
wollte sie produkte rausholen den preis
ermitteln bei amazon aber einmal suche
ich bei amazon.de sondern bei amazon.com
und wundert sich warum alles mit donnern
angegeben wird also das haben wir jetzt
nicht so verwunderlich sondern dass
alles auf englisch da stand sonst jedoch
jedoch einfach mal auf amazon.de es weil
dann ist alles simpel espanyols er fest
dass der westen das mal kurzen runde auf
spanisch sprechen hallo alex etwa der
billigste von 19 99 ist mir auch egal
das war's mit dem videoblog natürlich es
hat euch ein bisschen unterhalten und
wenn das der fall ist und auf jeden fall
jetzt mal daumen nach oben
wir sehen uns dann am dienstag
spätestens wieder dienstag 19 uhr kommt
neues video ich freue mich auf euch ich
hoffe ihr hattet alle fleißig eincheckt
instagram ab und ja mehr wollte man
nicht sagen wir müssen jetzt ganz
schnell zum zug weil sonst kommen wir
nicht nach hause also ich nicht hat rein
hab ich liebe was soll ich das nicht
sagen ich liebe euch gorges goji
smoothie übrigens schaut geht raus ein
crazy delicious